foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar from
bench to bedside targeted Gene editing
I am Marie Stone of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by Millipore Sigma to learn more visit
Sigma aldrich.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker
Jennifer Bennett PhD product manager
Millipore Sigma Jennifer you may now
begin your presentation
thank you for that introduction hi all
uh as she said I'm Jennifer Bennett and
I'm excited to tell you today about some
of the products that we have from bench
to bedside for targeted Gene editing
first the life science business of Mercy
GAA darmstadt Germany operates as
Millipore Sigma in the U.S and Canada
Lee creating Therapeutics has been the
purview of large pharmaceutical
companies who have the budgets and the
production equipment for lengthy
Discovery pre-clinical and clinical
studies but as therapies have expanded
from small molecules to include novel
modalities like monoclonal antibodies
antibody drug conjugates and cell and
gene therapy uh
these have expanded out in the number of
companies that can work on them outside
of Pharma companies in parallel the
tools to innovate and generate these
therapies have expanded becoming less
expensive and more accessible to
researchers outside of the
pharmaceutical companies
however all researchers still need to
follow this high-level paradigm
first designing the experiment what are
you trying to solve and how do you plan
to do it evaluating and validating
choosing and validating your reagents
of course then creating the model that
you're going to use to both test and
build your therapy
evaluating or assessing your model by
whole model approaches including high
content Imaging genomics proteomics
metabolomics sometimes whole genome
sequencing and then re-uh doing this
multiple times during the discovery
process until this is optimized for
efficiency where then we move into the
translation phase where the model can be
tested for safety and efficacy in the
clinical trials and we provide the tools
and expert technical support along this
workflow for every step through this and
so we're going to focus on an
application
um targeted Gene editing that mirrors
this workflow today
so functional genomics sits at the Nexus
of Discovery using sequencing and
bioinformatic tools and applications in
understanding and treating disease
functional genomic tools help us to
evaluate the complex Junction between
genotype and phenotype and often help us
move from Theory to practical
application
functional genomics is a practical
science designed to bring together the
genomics and the phenotype closer
together and connect all of these As you
move towards your therapy and the
revolution of engineered models using
functional genomic approaches helps to
identify phenotypes isolate critical
factors determine biological mechanisms
assay outcomes assay new novel drugs and
modalities create experimental models in
both animals and cell lines and of
course in bioproduction
one area of functional genomics that has
grown of course in the genome
engineering over the years has evolved
toward more Precision in gene
modification and editing new discoveries
have been recognized and created more
efficient engineering tools from
chemicals that could create advantageous
gene mutation to store Short stretches
of RNA that could silence genes to
proteins that could be engineered to
both bind and cut specific sequences of
DNA these have continued to evolve and
the most recent of that is crispr
crispr in fact began as a study of the
bacterial immune system but quickly
became a tool for creating model systems
and investigating diseases specifically
those that could not be investigated
from previous Gene editing systems
crispr screening technology opened new
Doors by providing versatile and simple
tools for high throughput investigations
and crispr has moved very quickly into
the clinic in just a decade five or six
in fact new therapies have been approved
by the FDA and over 50 clinical trials
are currently being conducted using
crispr gene editing reagents
but continue crispr continues to evolve
as new variants and new combinations are
invented to make that editing more
precise and safe for clinical use
so when people talk about the uses of
crispr and crispr-mediated Gene editing
they're usually talking about
nuclease-based creation of double strand
breaks when using nucleus-based crispr
Technologies we're really relying on
endogenous DNA repair mechanisms to
achieve the desired modification
the outcomes are achieved either through
non-homology and joining or homology
dependent repair or HDR
there are some tools and strategies that
can shift this balance a little bit
between these Pathways but it's not
really your choice which mechanism the
cell uses to repair the double strand
break and it predominantly uses
non-homology end joining often resulting
in loss of function mutations caused by
frame shifting insertions or deletion
one important difference between these
two Pathways is the error free repair
and error per prone repair compared to
repairing off of the plasmid
homology dependent repair requires the
addition of a donor DNA template
for which to
um pull the the DNA off and integrate
into your target Gene of choice of
course when this repair pathway is done
endogenously in the cell it often uses
very similar sequences off of a sister
chromatid but in this case you'd be
introducing the DNA of interest that
you'd like to integrate integrate again
the default pathway tends toward
non-homology end joining and an HR is
mostly inefficient in many therapeutic
cell lines which makes this an area of
interest for increasing this to get new
mutations and substitutions
with crispr and with other genome
engineering tools you can achieve a wide
array of genetic modifications
so here we're looking at various places
on a gene where we can add in make
modifications using genome engineering
tools specifically with crispr as well
the predominant application most common
is usually a gene knockout and again
this uses that non-homology end joining
where creating a double strand break in
a Nexon results in insertions or
deletions of nucleotides
leading to a frame shift and incorrect
expression of that Gene generally a
knockout
but there are multiple other genomic
manipulations that can be achieved again
we talked about with HR integration so
for example fusing a reporter Gene
putting in a gfp construct behind your
Gene so that you can follow it in the
cell line this can be done with crispr
by putting in a donor gfp sequence to be
integrated at this site
the choice of which type of genetic
modification is critical to the success
of either the model that you're creating
or the therapeutic you're designing
so let's take a look at how some
researchers have used crispr in their
drug development pipeline
pde 10A is a phosphodiesterase that
inactivates both camp and cgmp and is
almost exclusively expressed by neurons
in the striatum a brain area often
targeted by antipsychotic drugs
researchers sought to inhibit pde 10A as
a novel therapeutic Avenue to discover
antipsychotics
they use the fluorescently tagged triple
knock-in u2os cell line
featuring endogenous tagging of three
Gene targets with different fluorescent
proteins so we have Alpha tubulin tagged
with gfp in green
lamin B1 is tagged with bfp and beta
actin is tagged with RFP in red
a cell-based assay involving high
content Imaging was used by researchers
to identify a microtubule aggregation
phenotype that along with other
phenotypes was used as a measure of
toxicity
in a we have a DMSO control when added
to the cells that have been typed the
cortisol is a known as a positive
control it's a drug known to create
microtubule aggregation and that's seen
here in those pictures
the researchers then tested two
different compounds compound 8148 and
compound zero five five eight and when
added to the cells they could tell the
difference in the phenotypes by the
tagged microtubulin
from these assays researchers were able
to eliminate compounds that would have
resulted in late stage failures costing
the company Millions
crispr is enhancing the early Discovery
workflows to provide more accurate
information before moving into those
pre-clinical stages
often Discovery work will include
functional genomic screening screening
at the whole genome pathway or family
level to identify crucial targets for
action and as we move down this funnel
the gene editing workflow decreases in
scale while increasing in specificity
and efficiency
while screening is an important tool for
which we offer several off-the-shelf and
custom reagents in this webinar we are
going to focus on editing of single
genes
so whether you're starting from
functional genomics screening hits that
have been validated or you know your
target of interest already and want to
just attack it without having to go
through screening
this next workflow can outline as a very
basic outline for how to perform these
crispr experiments
so again the first step is to determine
the type of modification you need to
make and in what model system and it
will have a large impact on the
downstream design
next we need to design the guide rnas
and choose a nucleus this step can
actually be quite overwhelming for new
users there's many different varieties
of nucleases many programs with which to
design guide rnas and many places to
Target those guide rnas
using our crispr design tool you can
actually put in the gene ID or a custom
sequence and get back guide RNA designs
that we've stratified by efficiency and
specificity for you we also have
pre-designed guide RNA sequences
targeting the majority of the how mouth
and human genomes that have been
validated and they come from different
libraries like the Sanger Library
then it's a matter of choosing the
appropriate nucleus for example will you
be using a wild type cas9 our new cas9
plus a cas9 nicase and which format are
you going to use
nucleases and guide rnas can be
expressed to be a plasmids mRNA
lentiviral constructs
or as purified and synthetic material
each format has its limitations and its
advantages depending on your end goal
at this stage it's important to clarify
your end goal to make sure you're using
the appropriate reagents do you intend
to use crispr reagents to modify a cell
line that can be used in cell therapies
or are you making a disease model line
that you can use to screen drug
compounds those are just two examples of
the many uses but knowing this up front
and selecting the right reagents will
save you time and trouble down the line
the next step is to introduce your
crispr complexes into your model system
of choice and evaluate the modification
efficiency
ideally you would choose several guide
RNA designs and introduce all of them in
parallel to choose the ones with the
highest efficiency
a t-71 digestion can give you a quick
evaluation to eliminate the guide rnas
that are not going to work and further
sequencing protein expression phenotypic
or morphological assays can be done to
confirm the guide RNA is in fact
creating the Target that creating the
modification that you want additionally
off target analysis can be done at this
stage
specificity for the Target sequence is a
key component of every crispr complex
and the more you know about possibly
deleterious mutations outside of your
target Gene the better suitage you'll be
when you go to translator model
foreign depending on the efficiency seen
in this step you may need to optimize
your experiment and this can mean
changing the delivery method or trying
new conditions
designing new guide rnas in fact
choosing a different nucleus
and we've spoken to many researchers who
choose to move to higher quality or
higher performing reagents at this step
to increase the efficiency of their
chosen modification
using those high quality reagents will
make creating your model more successful
this may mean several iterations of this
going back all the way redesigning
choosing and going through again
it's an again it's an iterative process
and you continue to make it more
efficient as you move forward
once you've settled on the most
efficient reagents and have optimized
it's time to create your model
from there do you need to isolate or
select certain modified or edited cells
do you need to perform whole genome
sequencing
Lots can be done at this stage again to
look at the entirety of the model
and then once the model is created you
can be ready to move to the translation
stage where the focus is on scaling up
the therapeutic testing it in Vivo and
demonstrating the safety of the model
for this first part of the talk we're
going to focus on the first two areas of
this workflow designing and evaluating
efficiency and we're going to talk about
our Discovery portfolio that has many
different products for these two steps
foreign
while you can in fact use multiple
formats for your guide RNA and nucleus
we're going to focus on two that we
believe will be most efficient for
Downstream analysis
and that's the use of caste nucleases in
the purified protein format and
synthetic guide rnas
there are several advantages to the rnp
system so that combination of a purified
protein and a synthetic guide
first has very low cytotoxicity
introducing these into most cell lines
won't cause a toxic response a classic
example is using primary T cells
introducing exogenous DNA invokes a
cytotoxic response of the T Cell It's
effectively doing its job it's meant to
get rid of exogenous DNA so for crispr
that's not a great that's not great if
you want to modify primary T cells the
rnp complex reduces that possibility
rmps are also transient which is great
for therapeutic safety measures
introducing a plasmid or even an mRNA
that contains the crispr reagents those
reagents in the plasmid or mRNA form
live much longer inside the cell line
when they're introduced and therefore
the chances of them creating off-target
edits or modifications goes up with
proteins and the rmp complex most are
cleared within 48 to 72 hours following
introduction again reducing that off
target editing but causing the downside
that we need high efficiency reagents in
order to ensure High editing in that
short window
rnps then therefore have high on target
specificity because of their transients
they do work in non-dividing cell lines
they don't rely on the cell to express
like they do in the plasmid format so
you can put them in non-dividing primary
cells again a key model for therapeutic
development
and they don't leave any genomic
Footprints so they won't integrate into
your into the endogenous genome they're
there they're expressed and they get
degraded and move out
we have two different types of guide RNA
are available one is our two-part system
and the one part system the two-part
system involves a crrna which contains
that protospacer motif
about 20 nucleotides matching the target
sequence uh in the in your Gene of
Interest
and a standard Tracer RNA that would be
the same for every experiment
the sgrnas single guide RNA combines the
CRNA and Tracer into one and there is
some research that suggests these are
more efficient than the two-part system
both the sgrna and the CRNA when made
synthetically can have stabilizing
modifications added on to them to reduce
the possibility of RNA degradation once
introduced into the cell
so let's take a look at the many
different options that we have for cas9
proteins in our Discovery portfolio
the first two that were published and
discovered of course are our wild type
cas9
and a new one that was that was created
a variant created shortly after the wild
type which is called the Nicos
so the wild type cas9 generally has very
high Gene editing activity many people
use wild types still today despite new
variants
the Nick Ace on the other hand instead
of making a double strand break like the
wild type it instead only Nicks one of
the two strands therefore increasing its
specificity the downside with this is
because it only next one strand you
actually need to have both you need to
have two sets of guide rnas with Nick
aces in order to utilize the repair
pathway and get the indels or the
integration that you want
however it is more specific than the
wild type
another variant that we offer in the
ornp format that came shortly after the
wild type is What's called the dead cas9
so this utilizes uh the Nick Ace
mutation and adds another one on top
this cas9 and bind to the DNA but it
doesn't cut it
and this cas9 is the basis for much of
the crispr inhibition and crispr
activation work that's done for
regulating gene expression without
causing those heritable mutations
one of the ones that we want to go a
little bit in more in depth into today
is our cas9 plus variant
and this has both High editing activity
and on target activity and I'm going to
show you how we developed that
so first as I said the wild type cast9
has very high on target activity but as
we as many researchers and we discovered
through protein engineering of the wild
type cas9
there is a balance between the editing
activity for the Target Gene and editing
activity for off targets or what we what
we call specificity
such that if you try to make the cas9
um or I'm sorry such that this wild type
cast9 because it has very high activity
on Target also tends to edit anything
that's slightly related to your On
Target Gene one two three base pair
mismatches often get edited as well so
the traditional wild type has very low
specificity
from that came the enhanced specificity
cas9 where researchers undertook protein
engineering efforts to increase the
specificity they found they could make
mutations within the cas9
protein that would reduce the off-target
editing and therefore increase
specificity the unfortunate side effect
is that it also reduced the On Target
activity so there's a balance here
between On Target and off Target and
when you make changes to one often the
other is affected
so what we did through multiple rounds
of protein engineering
is look for a cas9 that had both High On
Target activity and high specificity we
tested both in parallel through the
development of this variant and we came
up with a new variant a novel variant
that we call cas9 Plus
here on this graph here we have a look
at the On Target activity and we are
comparing wild-type cas9 in purple the
ESP cast 9 in blue a competitor cas9 in
green and our cas9 plus here in yellow
and when we look at three different
targets in HEK cells we actually see
that the cas9 plus maintains high levels
of Hot On Target activity as you see
here in blue what I just told you on the
previous slide that ESP cas9 had very
low activity across the three the three
sites
but what's great here with the On Target
activity is when we look off Target we
look at a close
um off-target sequence that was
differing by a single base pair we
actually see that the cas9 plus does not
edit there see here in purple how the
wild type will edit at this off Target
site at all three Gene targets but the
cas9 plus does not in fact the cas9 plus
has even lower off target editing than a
high fidelity competitor variant as well
so it combines the high specificity of
the ESP cas9 with the high on target
activity of the wild type to make the
most efficient cas9 Plus
the discovery work that's done
um again the the guide RNA design and
choice is a is a crucial component of
the crispr complex and we offer standard
single guide rnas that can complex with
the cas9 plus to perform this editing
here we're looking at a graph of
multiple Gene targets looking at indel
activity comparing the standard sgrna so
this is the one part strna 2A came
competitors standard desalted sgrna and
here when complexed with cas9 plus and
transfected into HCC cells we see that
the standard guide in cas9 Plus have
significantly have very high activity
across the board at all sites and in
fact are has significantly more activity
than a competitor guide
foreign
there was no loss of viability so one of
the key
aspects of guide rnas because they are
synthesized is that they may carry with
them artifacts from the synthesis
reaction that could cause toxicity in
your model of interest and of course as
models get more sensitive moving to
primary cells moving to animal models
that toxicity Associated toxicity with
your crispr components is a key variable
that you need to assess when choosing
your complex reagents
and we can show that our standard sgrnas
in fact offer very little toxicity and
in fact are better than a competitor uh
in this space
and therefore the cast 9 plus with
standard guide rnas are a high efficient
highly efficient editing complex for
most model systems
another tool that we have in our
Discovery bucket that can help in your
workflow is our cas9 gfp
so this is really great because it
allows visualization of Gene editing
it's in fact a fantastic tool for an
optimization of your delivery conditions
often the addition of a gfp to a protein
can have an effect on its function but
as you can see from the graph cas9 gfp
maintains very high activity just like
the wild type cas9 variant on which it's
based and it does so better than
competitor versions that are attached to
gfp the image on the left shows how
castling gfp can be used to measure
delivery efficiency by measuring the
number of gfp positive cells
we work with several researchers both
internal and as collaborators to use gfp
to evaluate different formulations of
complexes for delivery
in fact one of the key trends in the
crispr field is on nanoparticle
lipoprotein particles different delivery
methods for the crispr reagents for
therapeutic uses cas9 GSP is a great
tool when you're trying to optimize a
new delivery system or evaluate a new
delivery system for your therapeutic
because it allows both editing and
visualization in onecas9
once you have your reagents designed and
you've started your experiments
um one constant need throughout the
workflow is to continually evaluate the
amount of editing that is occurring and
there are multiple methods that differ
in sensitivity
um the the time it takes to do them and
the cost to evaluate those editing
outcomes
three of them are outlined here the t-71
digestion kit which will go into a
little bit more in a moment it measures
indole size and efficiency estimates
we recommend that it can be used for
optimization of experimental design for
example in those early phases where
you're maybe designing five six seven
different guide RNA sequences to test
out this is again a great one to very
quickly give you an answer of which
guide RNA sequence is going to work and
which ones need to be trashed
it doesn't require specialized equipment
no bioinformatic analysis it has the
same day turnaround time and it's very
um uh cost efficient comes in a single
kit that you can do the entire
experiment in one day
Sanger sequencing in Next Generation
sequencing provide much more detailed
sequence information from the target
site of course these involve pcring up
your target site of interest
and then usually sending them out for
reading on special instruments right and
then the the sequence reads will come
back so bioinformatic analysis is in
fact required of those to determine how
much of the sequence actually is cut and
how much is not it has a longer
turnaround time and it tends to be more
expensive however uh
they will be more sensitive both Sanger
and next-gen sequencing will give you
more sensitive estimates of how much
editing is done so again we recommend
maybe to start with the t71 to weed out
the guide rnas that don't work and as
you're optimizing further down you want
to confirm that with these higher
sensitive methods
a little bit further into the t71 assay
kit that we offer the first step here is
to isolate your genomic DNA from your
edited self you will PCR amplify your
target region that has been edited
there's a denaturation step and then a
re-annealing so what happens is these
little pink spaces in here are
presumably the edit of interest and as
they are denatured they come apart into
single stranded pieces and when
re-annealed they don't always match up
perfectly and what you can get is
mismatched duplexes so on one strand
will be a mutation or an edit and on the
other strand might be a wild type that
didn't get edited and those are the
duplexes that are cleaved by the t7
endonuclease
then you run those out on a gel and what
you'll see is a pattern of in a negative
control you'll see no cutting because
everything was wild type and in
something that has been edited you
should see a banding pattern underneath
that should match up with where your
expected mutation was
here's an example a typical example of
the right here where we have our um our
transfection control that didn't have
editing reagent and then the edited
cells themselves you see there's still
some amount that was not edited and you
can use Imaging analysis to give a rough
estimate of the ratio of these bands to
get a rough efficiency number of how
well your guide rnas are doing again
this is a very fast low-cost method for
easy efficiency
so we've looked at these first two steps
and a number of the discovery products
that we have available to address them
now let's look at this back end of the
model
so as I mentioned remember when I
mentioned that the optimization often
requires higher quality and higher
performing reagents and that many
researchers switch to higher efficiency
reagents at this stage well we've
innovated a new portfolio of products to
address those needs and promote success
in your translational work
foreign ly launched translational grade
crispr reagents are engineered to meet
Superior manufacturing standards that
enable consistent and high quality
performance every time this new
portfolio is called Pure edict crispr
products
while our Discovery products are
appropriate for most of your early
Discovery and even some of your
pre-clinical study
studies are pure edit products in fact
have the highest performance higher
quality standards and quality
documentation that make them
the appropriate choice and the best
choice as you're moving your Discovery
work through pre-clinical and into
clinical research phases
Clifford's Evolution has of course
included a rapid move into the clinic
where crispr reagents are being used to
generate cell and Gene therapies to cure
a number of human health issues and
diseases
the attraction or one attraction of
crispr is that the change is permanent
so that change is embedded in the DNA of
the patient which prevents long-term
treatments or long-term drug use to
control the symptoms
additionally cures for rare genetic
diseases for which not much about the
biological mechanism is known are now
relatively easy with crispr or at least
easier than before and as part of the
democratization of creating new
therapies a number of new therapeutic
companies have sprung up in the wake of
crispr who Focus specifically on using
crispr reagents for Therapies
and the promise of crispr as a
therapeutic was a major contributing
reason why within 10 years of the first
publication the Nobel Prize was awarded
to Jennifer doudna and Emmanuel
charpentier
so let's dig a little bit deeper into
the pure edit portfolio and why it's
perfect for translational or therapeutic
research for Crispers
first as we discussed earlier the
advantages of rnps these advantages play
out for Therapeutics as well these are
all key points load cytotoxicity
transients which leads to higher safety
working in therapeutically relevant cell
model systems and of course no
integration into the genome leading to
no long-term Downstream effects all of
these are key points in why rnps are
quickly becoming the choice the format
of choice for therapeutic model
development
so if we look at the two different
pieces of this rnp complex
we have a pure edit cas9 protein in our
portfolio as well as a pure edit sgrna
our periodic cas9 protein has the
highest activity of any cas9 protein
that we offer it's also got the highest
specificity of any of the proteins that
we offer or that we've tested
it has 95 Purity and it's available off
the shelf
our periodic guide rnas again have
highest activity and Purity similar to
the protein we uh include stabilizing
modifications to prevent the degradation
these are made as custom products in
seven to ten business days and that's
the the quick delivery turnaround time
for that as well combining the periodic
guide RNA with the periodic gasoline
protein gives you the most efficient
calcium complex
for your translational work
so let's take a little bit more look at
the data associated with this
so first to look at the On Target
activity here we're looking at periodic
cas9 in red a competitor High Fidelity
two competitor High Fidelity cast lines
in yellow and blue and you see here
um
two different Gene sites in two
different cell lines the periodic cas9
is significantly higher On Target
activity than two other High Fidelity
variants
foreign
when we compare the On Target activity
to the off Target activity and plot that
as a ratio you see that the pure edit
has the highest ratio High ratio in this
case is good it means there's a lot of
On Target activity with very little
off-target activity that ratio is three
uh six-fold six-fold higher than the
nearest competitor this is incredibly
important for Therapeutics because you
do not want to have any off Target
affects any deleterious mutations as
part of your therapeutic that's a key
safety parameter that's going to become
more important than more strict as it's
moving forward with crispr into the
clinic
so when we dive into that specificity a
little bit more uh what we did here is
um here on the left the the letters are
representing nucleotides in the
protospace OR motif
and in red are the nucleotides that we
changed
uh and so off-target effects of course
it means that that sequence that 20 base
sorry 20 nucleotide sequence
is very similar to the 20 nucleotide
sequence that you're trying to change
sometimes they only differ by a single
base pair sometimes as many as two three
four base pairs as you increase the
number of nucleotides different between
your On Target and a different sequence
the spec or the chances the likelihood
of editing at that off Target site go
down with only a single base pair
difference there's a very high
probability that this sequence would be
edited in to the same extent that the
original Target sequence was
so we made Single base pair mutations
across the length of the protospace or
motif
to look at how single base single
nucleotide mismatches affected the
specificity of the periodic castline and
you can see here in yellow is the
periodic cas9 and in purple is a high
fidelity competitor
resoundingly and across the board at two
different sites and at every base pair
we've tested the periodic cas9 has
significantly lower activity in most
places even in some places even when
it's only differing by a single base
pair there's almost the activity is
almost non-existent again this is a very
important parameter for Therapeutics and
so minimizing the chances that it would
interact with any off-target site is key
for moving things forward as a therapy
so not just the cas9 is important for
this very specific and highly efficient
complex but also the periodic guides are
important so our Pure edit single guide
rnas are purified by hplc which gets rid
of and actively selects out any small
nucleotides sequences that could be left
over as well as other Trace Amounts in
in the
final product
here what we've done is compare our peer
edit and our standard guides across two
different cell lines actually three
different signs HEK T cells and a mouse
cell line at a number of different
targets and you can see at every Target
site the pure edit guide rnas have a
little bit have more activity than the
standard guides
again suggesting that if high quality
High editing and specificity is key to
your work the Purity guide RNA is going
to be the way to go complex with our
peer edit cas9 protein
so what we have here are two different
tiers of portfolios with products to fit
in every application our Discovery
portfolio and our peer edit portfolio
our Discovery portfolio is going to
focus on versatility ease of use pricing
and delivery time of course and it
contains many of the cas9 proteins that
we've talked about wild type cas9 plus
our castling gfp and of course our
standard guide rnas our Pure portfolio
is focusing on high performance highest
quality standards quality documentation
and is driven for therapeutic research
and these there are two products in this
portfolio as of now per edit guides and
periodic cas9 it's important to note
that
um
you don't only have to use peer edit
products at the very late stages of your
your workflow the earlier you bring in
the high efficiency products the faster
your timeline will go
as mentioned as part of that workflow
often multiple rounds of optimization
have to be done to get to the final
complex before you create your model
pure edit guides in cas9 can cut down on
that amount of optimization by giving
you the highest efficiency early on in
the process and reduce your overall time
to the clinic or to your your
pre-clinical studies
so we're constantly adding and always
working on adding new and Innovative rnp
products in both of these tiers to
address our the evolving needs of
researchers at various stages in gene
editing and I'm going to highlight one
of those ongoing initiatives for you
next
foreign
genome engineering tools that we're
working on is what we call crispr Chrome
and this involves a cas9 variant that is
fused to chromatin remodeling peptides
when we look compare three different
variants of fusions compared to the wild
type castmine we look at indel rates
and first here you see in Gray is the
wild type SP cas9 that has a very low
number of indels so this could be a gene
these are Gene targets that are
generally hard to edit
multiple rounds of Gene editing have
shown us that there are some Gene
targets that are just inherently more
difficult to edit than others for
various reasons one reason could be that
the chromosome architecture chromatin
architecture around them prevents
accessibility to the crispr complexes
and so here you see all of these four
percent four percent 3.8 and 2.2 these
Gene targets are very difficult to edit
and basically making any therapeutic
that would Target these or other targets
that are difficult like them virtually
impossible how do you how do you get to
a therapeutic if you only get two
percent editing
what we see here is that by fusing on
these chromatin remodeling peptides we
actually increase the indel activity
sometimes as much as five to six fold
across the board for all of them having
25 of cells being edited is much more
workable cell number than only four
percent and this makes the therapeutic
possible at this point
additionally we've looked at how these
variants compare
uh to the wild type cas9 when we're
trying to integrate a piece of DNA so we
have very low integration here six and a
half percent with the wild type but
these variants show increased as much as
five to almost six-fold here across all
of them again taking that efficiency
higher to allow this uh therapeutic
strategy to be successful where it would
not have been in the first place
and this is just one example of new
technology and Innovations for our rmps
that we're working on
so what's next for crispr and crispr
Therapeutics so to date many of the
Therapeutics and and the kind of the
headlines that I showed you have largely
focused on on easier targets the the low
hanging fruit if you will but there's a
number of different areas where
Therapeutics are moving uh in kind of
that next Generation uh genome
engineering it's including inserting DNA
to repair a place harmful DNA sequences
Multiplex editing so multiple genes
being edited at one time you can imagine
that this increases deficiency while
decreasing safety concerns if you can if
you can edit two to three genes at once
you don't have to go back and do them
sequentially a lot less time for
off-target edits to occur
uh base editing and and Prime editing
are two new forms of what are would have
been termed Precision editing where
they're using crispr components to
directly change bases without making
double strand breaks in the base editing
you can directly change single DNA bases
and in Prime editing you can change both
single bases and longer stretches of DNA
the advantage here is that without the
double strand breaks there's less impact
to the remainder of the genome it
doesn't create breaks everywhere else in
the genome and have that off Target so
again safer and more precise
and of course then crispr inhibition and
crispr activation the ability to turn
jeans on and off without making breaks
at all uh is a key area of therapeutic
research as well
so what do we need what does crispr need
to be successful in Translation what do
we need to continue to work on to get it
to this stage
first better specificity without
decreasing efficiency and I showed you
one variant that we have well two
variants the cas9 plus and the periodic
cas9 in which we have increased
specificity without without decreasing
that efficiency variants that have this
are going to be key candidates to move
forward more precise editing
editing single nucleotides
inefficient Precision editing can limit
the field to therapies where Gene
functions need to be eliminated or where
corrected cells gain a competitive
advantage over the unrepaired cells
additionally improved access to Target
sites so right now
um we are limited to targets that have
Pam proximal regions as well as to sites
that can be efficiently edited so
inclusion of variance to the nucleases
that expand our accessibility to the
rest of the genome virtually making it
able for a researcher to edit anywhere
that they want
without limitation will be key at moving
forward and finally delivery delivery is
another key factor here whether the
crispr reagents are being used to modify
a cell line and the cell line becomes
the therapeutic introduced into the
patient or the crispr reagents
themselves or the therapeutic introduced
into the patient the delivery of that
can have a huge impact on the efficiency
of it as a therapeutic but also on the
safety of it and so continuing to
innovate in new methods of delivering
new safer
methods of delivery is going to be key
to continue to pushing crispr forward
so as I've shown you throughout this
webinar we provide a number of solutions
that can cover the end-to-end workflows
for bench to bedside using gene editing
thank you for your attention to this and
I will take any questions
thank you Jennifer for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started
is pure edit cas9 different from cast 9
plus
that's a that's a great question and so
the base cas9 variant the mutations in
cas9 that make it more specific and
highly active are the same for cas9 plus
and pure edit cas9 the difference
between the two is the pure edit cas9
has an enhancer in it that raises that
level of activity even higher over the
base cas9 plus and so that's present
only in the periodic cas9 and and
potentially in future periodic cas9
products as well
all right thank you
um next question
does the t7 E1 assay kit contain the DNA
polymerase and the master mix to perform
the PCR
yeah that's a good question so the kit
does contain the master mix it does not
contain the DNA polymerase and the
reason one of the biggest reasons for
this is that
um
the the PCR conditions including the
polymerase may already be worked out in
your own lab you may already be using a
DNA polymerase and have optimized PCR
conditions for your Gene interest that
you would then like to use
um to amplify that DNA to do the t71 so
this way you can use a pre-optimized
protocol
um if if you don't have one or you would
like to buy a polymerase from us we've
actually worked out with the kit how to
use and get the best results with our
accutac DNA polymerase and that data can
be found in our t71 page and is also
linked on the t71 product page so you
can buy them both at the same time
great thank you
um next question this has
um kind of two parts to it so looking uh
looking forward to Future uses of pure
edit
um Can the cast will the cas9 be able to
be conjugated to gfp
um and will the crispr portfolio utilize
primer or base editing
yes so this is very forward-looking
right of course this portfolio for Pure
edit is new just launched this year and
as we move toward more Precision Gene
editing I think we're all looking
forward to base editing and Prime
editing
um the gfp conjugation itself makes cas9
a good molecule for tracking that
transfection efficiency so I think these
are all options for the peer edit
portfolio in the future and I would
encourage anybody who wants to be kept
aware of these options to sign up on our
website and so we'll we'll be sending
out information
to users and customers on a regular
basis to to keep them updated on the
newest products that we have in this
portfolio
thank you
next question do you have any do you
have a library of Gene Knockouts such as
RNA binding protein Gene KO Library
yes we do have several options for
libraries for Gene knockout we also have
several options for shrna binding
libraries
um these are all present on our website
we utilize many of the
um the known knockout libraries that
have been published and you can find all
of those we have very large extensive
collections you can buy the entire
Library you could buy a subset of the
library you can buy pools of the library
apps actually the the options for your
custom built Library are pretty endless
with us right now I would encourage you
to get in touch with your
your sales representative or come online
through our customer service and we can
get somebody helping you build that
Library
great thank you
next question
um how how do you design grna for
prokaryotes and how would you validate
it
so that's a little different of an
approach from this everything that we've
talked about in this webinar has
um is from a million system right and so
something very interesting is that even
though crispr was found to naturally
exist in bacteria crispr and cas9 in its
normal State don't actually affect Gene
editing in prokaryotes and in bacteria
so we have devised a new system and you
can again find this on our website uh
it's our bacterial Gene editors it's a
cas9 fused to a traditional bacteria
editing system it's plasmids designed
specifically for work in E coli most of
these that you're going to find are not
going to be good for work in E coli
because they're they don't contain any
of the promoters and things necessary
for expression and bacteria so I would
highly advise you to go to our website
look for our cas9 back 1p products which
do work specifically in E coli
great thank you
um next question
what is the best delivery method for the
peer edit crispr product
uh so we've tested a number of delivery
methods and it's going to depend on the
model system that you used we recommend
electroporation and many of our results
are done with electroporation in the
immortalized and primary cell lines
because we find that's what gets the
highest efficiency and that in fact for
the peer edit that enhancer also has the
highest efficiency when done with
electroporation however we've also
tested it using lipofection kits and had
users tested with like micro injection
into embryonic models and both of those
still show same high efficiency so it
really can be optimized to whatever is
necessary for your model of choice
thank you next question
can I use pure edit cas9 with standard
sgrnas or peer edit SG rnas with a
different cas9 variant
yes you can and and so these are not
there's no magic formula between the
periodic guide and the periodic cas9
that makes them only work with each
other of course the best and most
efficient crispr complex is going to be
a periodic guide with a periodic cas9
however we do know that people are
working on their own cas9 variants maybe
in your lab you've done your own protein
engineering and you have a cas9 that you
really want to work with but you're
looking for a high efficiency guide art
guide RNA in that case you could easily
pair our periodic guides with whatever
cas9 variant you've already developed
and and so yes the obvious answer
is that they are not exclusive to each
other they can be used with other
variants
thank you
next question
for translation to Clinic how important
would it be to have GMP grade guide RNA
for complexing with GMP cast 9 to form
rnps
yeah so this is a great question
um and it underlies what you're going to
actually be using the crispr components
for
so if if you're using the crispr
components let's say as the therapeutic
the thing that you would directly inject
into a patient then in that case GMP is
very important once you get to that
clinical level because it's it's
obviously going directly into the
patient
however if you are going to use crispr
to modify a cell line and then that cell
line is in fact the therapy that's going
into the patient the crispr components
should themselves be of the highest
quality but do not have to be GMP grade
as as according to the regulations from
the regulatory bodies in in Europe and
in North America that is true right now
and so as you translate that cell
therapy into the clinic uh you can you
still need high quality crispr reagents
but they don't have to be GMP and that's
why this product is so good it gives you
that high quality with that high
activity in the pure edit but you're not
waiting the long custom times or paying
the price for the GMP that's unnecessary
for those early clinical stages
great thank you and it looks like we
have time for one more question
can I use pure edit crispr reagents even
if I'm not developing a therapeutic
yes yes of course we've talked a lot
about Therapeutics as part of this
webinar
um but that doesn't mean that if you're
creating a model to uh you know better
understand a biological pathway
um that you can't use the periodic
reagents peer edit is is designed to be
highly efficient so high specificity and
high activity and we recognize that
there's a place in early Discovery where
that high specificity is not always
required however if that is important
for your model if that's important for
your research then of course you should
be using the best reagents for your
experiment and the peer edit will do
that I mean it'll give you that high
specificity and high activity right off
the bat and so no if you're you are not
relegated to our Discovery portfolio if
you're not doing a therapeutic you
should feel free to choose anything
across either portfolio and mix and
match between the portfolios if
necessary
well thank you again Jennifer for your
time today and your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor Millipore Sigma for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time take care everyone
goodbye